welcome to this video playing Moscow I
cannot do that I cannot pronounce that
this was the brain pecker right let's
see I'm playing the modern defense I'm
inspired by this recent book by Tiger
Hill up pass on the Swedish Grandmaster
who wrote this new book the modern tiger
I'll probably do a review of this book
in in a short while okay this has
irritated him somewhat or it looks
totally normal i think 97 is also move
but b5 should be should be okay yeah
black is going for this early queenside
expansion anticipating a long castling
so let's see what the c5 okay he's
pushing quickly in the in the center
okay so before or not yeah I think I
should probably gain the space at a
moment where he does not have an active
place for this for this piece um so I
guess a five there is this e six idea
but it's difficult to play early at the
mean you can play it but it's not
helping him this is what I'm trying to
say okay is regrouping but this actually
gives me the chance to pick this this
Bishop up what I definitely want to do
get this Bishop so that after coming c5
my dark squared Bishop will gain I
should take it I should take it first no
aha what am i doing I'm playing it
really badly here i justjust I should
just take it and then I'm totally fine
and now we'll play age three and and
kick my knife back
like oh this is terrible this is really
terrible what I do here ah yeah this is
this is ruining my position here from
from from being a good to to being
problematic if at least he cannot easily
play a g4 because of the the long
diagonal but but still I should just
take the bishop yeah it's two bishops
and in an open position which is just
hugely favorable for me okay I can take
f3 now is this an idea or is it bad okay
come on let's just at least play quick
I'm playing badly I should at least do
this in a reasonable speed okay so going
to take him grabbing a pawn on d6 is
definitely not a problem this would
activate all my pieces so I'm not afraid
of that at all the Queen d6 is just just
very bad take it's doing that even so
knight to e 4r what exactly or to a
forum night a four is also valid but
this is this is better nigeria some is
it's a movement efore is definitely a
good place for the night he has no
development and this is just strange
that you went further for the trade oh
I'm further for the grab I mean for the
porn grab so what now Bishop to see 60 I
can also play 93 it's not a bad choice
but
okay let's keep keep them kick the rook
exchange the active rook I'm keeping the
advantages in the revolution anyway 93
those kind of things
okay so still this move on something
else would be eight it's not i mean i
can also push the pawn to a three yeah
maybe opening up the long diagonal it's
not bad yeah okay still go for that I
could have played 92 actually what would
have been interesting to just take g2
now this book would have been good
actually but ok he cannot take on c6
anyway yeah I know he does that check
here check on b2 can also go here it
cannot take on c6 because of checkmate
92 and a takes be too made so it's
getting very tactical here all of a
sudden
but that's not working right this is if
i takee 592 will pick up the piece yeah
I will pick up two pieces yeah that's
quite funny check here on be to check
King takes Knight c4 check and 90 x
musics two pieces yeah headwinds to
pieces thats it's nice to pieces is
quite a lot I have anything I probably
didn't play it in the best possible way
but grabbing only six is really not
possible that gives black so much
activity okay so yeah I will still win
this check his special check white
resides yeah I don't think you can take
on these six let's have a look here how
the compound is this it only gives like
0.5 it's climbing but interesting i
would have thought that this is really
like totally unplayable but it doesn't
seem to be that terrible okay okay so
i'm really interested how this is it's
still good compensation here but no
advantage according to the comp this
however losses due to 92 we have a day
three I just played this check too
quickly can just do that and it's really
it's really bad now yeah I want two
points on the King side which in which
adds up to one extra porn and I have the
bishop pale and well King bad night bed
and so on plus the edge porn will decide
so this was much better and a 3m but ok
this this is in fact here it's it's
totally lost here this is really nice
winning track and winning all pieces
check check yeah with Knight takes
Knight takes b6
coming coming as well yeah a key moment
was when I i forgot to take only 3 yeah
I just I just have to take III now of
course I shouldn't allow Bishop g1 I
just this was the idea all along and
something like this for example it's
just very nice for black I have a good
diagonal and it's just ok what you want
in this in this kind of opening its I
mean not much better or anything but for
the modern this is what you want good
good Bishop you can play e6 to sort of
yeah be a little bit more solid in the
center and why it is not having such a
totally clear plan what did you do ok
thanks for watching